revient sur une polémique qui ne cesse
de prendre de l'ampleur et qui part de
cette vidéo
vous y voit les joueurs du PSG se rendre
à Nantes dans un jet privé un trajet de
seulement 300 km qui a fait réagir le
directeur du TGV Paris-Nantes est en
moins de 2h en TGV je renouvelle notre
proposition d'offres TGV adaptée à vos
besoins spécifiques hier alors d'une
conférence de presse Christophe Galtier
et Kylian Mbappe ont été invités à lui
répondre
et deux hommes prennent donc ce sujet
avec humour une réaction qui a fait
bondir la mère de Paris Anne Hidalgo
elle vous choqué par la réaction de
Christophe Galtier qui vient Mbappé
avec nous journaliste sportifs et qui a
souhaité un soutien total à Christophe
Galtier est-ce qu'on peut revoir la
séquence en longueur s'il vous plaît
parce que c'est résumé on c'est nul
regardez
une question extra sportive et qui est
sportive puisque Alain crakovic
responsable des TGV à Twitter après une
vidéo de Marco verratti faisant Paris
Nantes et Nantes Paris en jet privé
Paris Nantes étant moins de deux heures
en TGV Inuit PSG inside je renouvelle
notre proposition d'offres TGV adaptée à
vos besoins spécifiques pour intérêt
commun c'est sécurité rapidité service
éco mobilité est-ce que c'est une
question que vous vous posez et est-ce
que vous en avez parlé à vos joueurs
[Rires]
excusez-moi
je me doutais
prenez la voir cette question là pour
être très honnête avec vous ce matin on
a parlé avec
la société qui organise nos déplacements
est en train de voir si on peut pas se
déplacer en char à voile
voilà
et vous sur la jet privé monsieur Mbappé
vous vous en pensez quoi
merci
c'est magnifique c'est magnifique
franchement c'est très drôle je suis
désolé Christophe est très drôle Killian
Mbappe aussi il faut arrêter la Gile
c'est insupportable et l'autre là Anne
Hidalgo qui ramène son grain de sel
la première ministre aussi qui s'immiste
cet après-midi
[Musique]
non mais il faut savoir comment ça se
passe un club de foot c'est d'abord
c'est pas Galtier qui décide des
sociétés comme il a dit non mais c'est
une société c'est à l'intérieur du club
il y a deux trois personnes qui
s'occupent de tous les déplacements ils
jouent à 21h ils finissent à 23 ils sont
prêts à minuit minuit et demi donc je
suis en train de me dire qu'ils
arriveraient à Montparnasse entre deux
heures et demie et 3h du matin Mbappe
Messi Neymar ils comment pour sécuriser
mon Parnasse à cette heure là il y a
entre 3000 et 5000 personnes non mais
moi je veux bien c'est c'est très noble
ce qu'ils disent mais c'est pas encore
une fois footeux à régler ce genre de
problème Gilbert si on est dans cette
condition là c'est quand même les
politiques qui nous ont mis c'est pas
Galtier ni Mbappé ville
l'été n'a eu aucun effet bénéfique sur
vous c'est-à-dire que vous revenez ici
et vous et vous allez non mais vous
prenez le parti du milieu du foot parce
que vous avez travaillé dedans longtemps
et toi tu prends le parti de Killian moi
je prends le parti du peuple et moi je
suis malheureux parce que j'aime Galtier
j'aime Mbappe j'aime le foot et là ils
ont fait mal au foot parce qu'ils sont
hors sol ces gens-là alors que le
Président de la République dit on va
avoir des difficultés similaires eux ils
disent mais on ira en char à voile comme
si il s'en fout cette Bretagne c'est
plus qu'une erreur de communication
pour ta gouverne comme tu es au courant
que tu sais tout mieux que tout le monde
le président Emmanuel Macron il a pleuré
pour Kemba pays reste il a pleuré
savoir que c'est pas c'est pas quand ça
les intéresse ils sont là si demain ils
sont en finale de la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar tu vas voir s'ils vont pas prendre
des avions pour y aller et pour être
propre au premier rang c'est-à-dire pour
courir pourquoi courir auprès d'eux donc
il faut qu'il arrêter de leur taper
dessus que Galtier une remarque il a une
remarque de quoi il a une remarque de
vestiaire mais ça tu peux pas savoir tu
es jamais rentré dans un vesti mais
quand tu as passé ton temps dans un
vestiaire tu sais comment ça se passe
comment aujourd'hui
j'attendais la question donc il était
préparé mais sa réponse c'est toi tu le
crois ça tu crois quand il dit il
attendait la question c'est posé par qui
est posé par un type que sur LCI qui
était au quotidien avant tu as jamais vu
un match de foot qui est venu là juste
pour les emmerder les choses sortez
journaliste
voilà le mec est venu c'est pour les
emmerder il est venu parle de foot on
joue la Juventus ce soir ils ont pas
posé une question je joue pas le stade
sable hein faut juste la Juventus
tiens des plus grands clubs au monde
mais non lui pose pas la question on lui
dit
alors que vraiment et le mec qui va
répondre il va finalement moi je veux
bien qu'on règle le problème du climat
en 2 jours en 2 ans il y a pas de
problème mais on a l'impression qu'on va
régler que la France va régler le
problème de la pollution comme ça mais
on peut on peut pas régler le problème
de comme ça
je vais vous dire
tu sais ce que c'était moi je suis tout
à fait d'accord pour le fait
qu'effectivement ils prennent des jets
pas l'avion il y a un match important ce
soir j'ai aucun souci avec ça en
revanche au moment où la France entière
à cause du réchauffement climatique à
brûler cet été que des gens perdu leur
baraque et leur commerce tu peux pas non
tu peux juste pas pousser
à chaque fois
tu ne trouves pas de rire tu ne peux pas
voir ce qui prennent des jets j'ai aucun
souci mais ne pas rire en pensant que
non ça arrive
aux enterrements y compris au moment
même venu au moment mal placé au 3
divorce de Castaldi j'ai rigolais en
terme de communication c'est pas
folichon
c'est un moment de vestiaire qui aurait
peut-être pas eu dû avoir lieu là mais
là il y a de la récupération politique
tout le monde
que 63% des déplacements de Ligue 1 et
de Ligue 2 se font en avion c'est pas
possible
arrêtez de dire les chiffres on s'en
fout il a raison Mathieu ce qui reproche
les gens à la limite moi moi je le
reproche pas parce que ça m'a fait
énormément rire c'est l'attitude voilà
ils ont rigoler
parce qu'il savait qu'ils allaient avoir
une question et ça les a fait marrer
voilà oui ils se sont regardés en
connivence parce que c'est des sales
gosses c'est qu'à ce moment-là
monsieur qui dit qu'ils ont eu un
comportement voilà
que Mathieu se foutent des jets ça je je
le comprends mais il faut les joueurs de
foot sont des joueurs de foot ils sont
c'est des gamins ils ont 23 ans je t'ai
dit c'est une réponse de vestiaires
donc Galtier mégalties c'est des je t'ai
dit c'est une réponse de vestiaire c'est
ce qui se passe dans un vestiaire quand
tu arrives ça arrête pas de vaner
s'arrête pas de semer comme ça ils se
sont dit que qu'est-ce qui nous pose
comme question on a autre chose à penser
hier soir il avait quand même autre
chose à penser Galtier pourquoi il était
rentré en jet on était pas rentré en
train voilà Gilles mais l'entraîneur du
PSG c'est un symbole vous vous rendez
pas compte Mbappé c'est un symbole c'est
eux disent on s'en fout c'est attitude
arrogante tous les jeunes qui les idoles
vont dérangent
pas c'est un sale gosse mais voilà mais
non
ça tous ensemble polémique il gagne la
Coupe du Monde ou qui gagne la Ligue des
Champions tu vas être le premier à crier
bravo et tu auras oublié qui s'est marré
à cette question il y a une polémique
mondiale vous l'expliquez comment il y a
une volonté
la Chine a mis 5 milliards dans la
nature là dans l'atmosphère tu en parles
mais lâcher on s'en fout c'est galère il
faut que tu te fous de la Chine à 5
milliards de CO2 dans l'atmosphère mais
par contre tu t'en fous pas que l'autre
il rigole à une question d'un peintre
parce que le mec qui lui a posé la
question c'est un pain ça nous fait
reculer 10 ans c'est bon Daniel Moreau
alors moi je suis vraiment exactement
comme ça c'est-à-dire que Galtier je
trouve qu'il a très bien répondu avec sa
vanne parce que c'est à la hauteur du
ridicule de cette polémique parce que
c'est évidemment pas un vol jet privé
qui va voilà en revanche moi j'ai
vraiment je n'ai pas du tout apprécié ce
fou rire et
excusez-moi il y a pas de chiffres
simplement sur les réseaux sociaux alors
que Kylian Mbappe tout le monde l'adore
là c'est très mal pris et ça c'est
vraiment dommage la réponse de Galtier
j'adore vraiment
oui ils sont pas du tout méprisants
pourquoi ils rigolent parce que la
question est complètement stupide et
c'est pas eux qui sont de 2h c'est le
journaliste qui est déconnecté des
réalités oui on peut faire Paris Nantes
en train on peut même le faire en
covoiturage mais est-ce que vous
imaginez ici
ça n'a pas de sens donc au bout d'un
moment il a voulu faire le malin et
voilà
l'écologie n'était pas important c'est
juste qu'on leur reproche
parce que sur le fond ils ont raison
mais ils ont été maladroit sur la force
déferlement que tu as vu non est-ce que
ça vaut se déterminer ça monte jusqu'au
premier ministre oui c'est une affaire
nationale mais toi tu es un cours d'eau
qui dépasse qui sort c'est un
déferlement tout seul donc on a on a les
chéris on a parce que il y a eu d'autres
questions aussi dans cette conférence de
presse qui était
ubuesque regardez
presque comment Nicolas perdu
american staff on est en train de nous
les mélanger oh je pense plus rien
[Applaudissements]
je suis complètement team Galtier
je trouve que ça fait du bien de rire et
de sourire même avec des sujets
importants et en fait on est dans une
écologie aujourd'hui totalement
culpabilisante et alors les hommes
politiques aujourd'hui qui essaient de
se faire de la pub alors immonde sur le
dos de Mappy
donne avec ces associations
politiques il y a un instant et c'est
vrai qu'il y a un truc maintenant ce qui
se passe avec les hommes politiques ce
qui est incroyable c'est comme ils
savent plus quoi faire ils savent plus
quoi penser ils vont sur les réseaux
donc ils ont des gars qui vont sur les
réseaux et ils viennent voir le
conseiller et il y a des conseillers qui
arrivent oui là Mbappé il y a une petite
polémique là sur les réseaux il se fait
défoncer donc là ils savent même pas de
quoi il parle ils disent ben fais moi un
tweet tiens pour dire que on est quand
même contre lui là ça va pas ce qu'il a
fait non mais les mecs ils savent même
pas de quoi il parle il voit les réseaux
sociaux ils disent tiens bah si ça va
d'un côté bah je vais d'un côté ça va de
l'autre je vais de l'autre c'est
n'importe quoi ils vont tous
également avait pris cause contre
Kylian Mbappe et Christophe galti
regardez pense que c'est important qu'il
réalise dans quel monde on est qui
prennent conscience qu'il y a une crise
climatique qui n'est plus une hypothèse
pour demain mais qui est une réalité
maintenant qu'on a tous vécu avec la
canicule avec la sécheresse avec les
incendies cet été et que chacun chacun
doit être bien conscient du monde dans
lequel on vit donc moi je les appelle à
prendre pleinement conscience de cette
situation à ce moment-là
elle est dans sa fonction après il passe
à parce que c'est vrai que c'est une
quelqu'un que je connais bien voilà et
dans sa fonction elle elle fait elle
fait un discours de Premier ministre moi
on va pas se mentir elle essaie de
ménager la servitude
est-ce que tu veux te marier avec moi je
vais réfléchir je suis désolé c'est vrai
voilà
regardez mettez-moi la 3 regardez on a
la troisième question mettez-moi la
troisième question qui a eu hier encore
c'était vraiment une conférence de
presse que
UPR
comment est-ce que vous pensez que cette
année Mathieu Delormeau nous ressortira
un documentaire sur Disneyland
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est magique non mais imaginez s'ils
avaient Paris et s'ils avaient répondu
premier degré oui en effet c'est très
grand c'est prête vraiment tu as raison
d'avoir pris un avion on aurait dit mais
espèce de focus vous êtes des hypocrites
de toute façon vous êtes en jet privé
tous les thés arrêtez n'importe quoi
je m'en fous qu'il prenne un jet ils ne
vont pas prendre le train c'est des
stars juste qui nous font rire
c'est pas tout à fait pareil je le dis
mais bon
insupportable et le nom du gars est
drôle aussi
on a on a une dernière question qui a
été posée hier à Kylian Mbappé regarde
comment que vous de l'élection de
Bertrand Renard de chiffre d'affe des
lettres oh je pense pas rien merci
[Applaudissements]
on m'a dit qu'on a encore une dernière
question regardez
a été faite par les hommes
on
[Applaudissements]
occulte assez volontairement je trouve
dans toute la presse le fait que en ce
moment même le PSG est en négociation
avec la SNCF justement pour les
déplacements en train exactement
négociation
sur le train retour parce que le PSG
veut qu'il y a des trains à 1h du matin
après leur match donc on leur tombe
dessus
très grand ami du football
surtout en termes de récupération il
joue tous les trois jours ils seront
jamais prêts pour une équipe de foot
c'est impossible frérot voilà donc voilà
donc je vous le dis il fallait répondre
ça a raison une fois de plus merci au
revoir ce qu'on pensait téléspectateurs
Gilles Favard a tort non voilà êtes-vous
choqué
[Applaudissements]